[Music]
David Cassidy's garage sale when he
passed away they were selling this I
picked up on it but we are we're hot
were the holidays right now yeah Merry
Christmas and happy little mermaid life
yes thank you very much
so this has to be a role that really
wins you points in your house I mean
you're a Disney fan but Caitlin's a
Disney fan she got a Cricut is that what
they're called and she's doing um she's
making enough of a little mermaid
costume to wear for tomorrow and she's
having a frozen to party at our house
next week which I'll be gone for your
usually game for everything I saw your
Halloween costumes so cute yeah and you
dress up because Billy loves that movie
right yeah I've been trying to get him
to watch Little Mermaid and I'll
literally put it on and my number will
come on it'll go Coco Coco Coco Coco
Coco he came down yesterday came down
the other day though and he he was timid
at first myself and then he got into it
he's running around with the little
crabs he wanted to go on stage and I'm
I'm rehearsing my number kind of for the
first time on the stage jumping on these
tables and knives and I like it here
yeah daddy Dada Dada Dada Dada is gonna
fall off the table if you don't shut up
kid but um good for you I mean you're
gonna rehearse with the knives and and
you know rehearse with the knives I mean
were they real nice well there's knives
there's the cleavers you'll see the
characters pop out and come to life I've
decided to play the chef insane and and
this is really why I love plants because
somehow I put on the mustache that
costume and then another just like a
complete nutter comes out I mean he's
he's bipolar just like you know it's
like he's just a flip-flopper you know
but it's just killing those fish he's a
serial killer for fishing crab I think
how about the kids you have a kid no I
was just gonna say can I borrow you can
he's cute
I saw an Instagram the other day I think
you just said you're overwhelmed with
happiness I am it's just one of those
times where you go like everything is
great and that's where you just have to
embrace it and
you know tie it up and hold it and tell
everybody you know because it's you know
life is goes like this you know but when
it's like that you go is he first words
yeah
Trust Fund where his first two words he
does talk he he says Coco
a lot he wakes up in the morning saying
Coco and then he says lilo is his dog
lilo lilo Coco Coco
mama mama well how did you perfect the
French accent I worked on it you know
it's um it's again it's like he's manic
you know and then then he's you know
[Music]
don't you do you look at roles now cuz I
know you're doing a new Disney Plus show
too but who do you look at roles and
think oh maybe like Billy might like
this role one day yes I knew it's more
about the wife than Billy right now but
I knew she would like this the Disney
Plus this show it's called big shots I
mean that I don't care if he elected her
I'm working with David E Kelly whether
my kid likes it or not the tough thing
about that was basketball i mean it i
i'm you know i'm really illiterate when
it comes to sports I've never been good
at any of it and I have really had to
dig in I went to a Clippers practice
with Jerry West where I said is this a
college team and he said get out so I
don't it was easier to learn the medical
terms on ER than it is these basketball
terms yeah well we know you love to sing
so I mean this live production is this
just in your wheelhouse you love it you
get nervous at all it I do love it but I
love it that it's in character I'm not a
great singer so I so to play a
characters you know playing it put all
this gorge all over it it is and I feel
sort of protected in this park because
it's a like I said it's a big character
dancers and you have the the sort of
Disney you know magic behind it all and
so I just hope I don't fall you're not
gonna fall
did you fall in practice no it's making
a new memory of Little Mermaid it's like
putting a cherry on top of what you love
already
[Music]